hey this is Eric from chess comm here  with Cara Nakamura we're at the whole  chess comm team here in Mexico we do a  meet up with the whole global team once  a year and this time the karo was kind  enough to join us and we're going to see  today  Picaro can beat every single member of  chess comm staff in a row so with that  good luck  because I'm reside  photoline the cars to do what it is yeah  pretend like you're thinking hard  picture oh yeah one more  ah see ya  well we thank grandmaster Takara  Nakamura for humbling the entire chess  comm team I'm going to try to prevent us  from being total mincemeat and see if we  can get one game on the last chance  ready set go okay he just slowed down  this is a mistake I've been here before  all right